[Musique]
elle et moi on s'est rencontré il ya 14
ans je l'avais déjà vue avant mais j'ai
vraiment appris à l'apprécier ces
derniers temps elle ne répète toujours
l'eau c'est la vie l'eau c'est le lien
l'os et le partage
elle sait ingo une toute petite goutte
d'eau
son nom signifie eau protectrice en
langues kanak
je la connais bien parce que je bosse
pour elle je suis chargé de coordonner
les actions publiques dans le domaine de
l'eau en nouvelle calédonie un sacré
challenge quand on connaît le
millefeuille administratif local
laventure bingo débute lorsque sous
forme de pluie elle quitte un nuage qui
survole la nouvelle calédonie mon pays
pendant sa chute
ingo calcul que son voyage va durer
quelques heures à peine car la nouvelle
calédonie est une toute petite île
perdue dans l'immense océan pacifique
captée par les feuilles d'un arbre son
atterrissage sur terre se fait en
douceur elle saute de branche en branche
et ruisselle le long du tronc du
magnifique banian qui l'a accueilli du
haut de ce point de vue ingo se rend
compte que la forêt est en mauvais état
il ne reste plus que les grands et vieux
arbres le sous bois a disparu
les mamans arbre lui explique que c'est
à cause des cochons sauvages et dessert
oui les soeurs c'est comme ça grandit
chez nous
les servent donc qui dévorent les jeunes
pousses les futures générations de forêt
les mamans arbre lui parle aussi de leur
peur du feu ce feu qui est toujours
d'origine humaine qui détruit tout sur
son passage et qui assèche les sols
43 millions d'hectares de forêt ont
disparu dans le monde ces vingt
dernières années
ingo est triste car elle sait que les
forêts sont une éponge naturelle un abri
privilégié pour les gouttes d'eau si la
forêt disparaît l'eau disparaît
ingo s'infiltre à présent le long des
racines et rejoint la rivière elle se
laisse porter et découvre les mines
qui défriche une énorme quantité de
terre et de sole pour extraire un
pourcentage assez faible de mes nerfs en
précieux
oui elle matanais pour qu'on aille voir
le seigneur des anneaux 5 fu
elle entend des coups des pelles
mécaniques et le roulement des camions
qui emporte loin cette terre autrefois
cocon douillet pour la forêt et pour
elle
elle découvre aussi les industries qui
utilisent une énorme quantité d'eau pour
refroidir les fours où les machines
l'irremplaçable
l'électricité et fabriqués grâce à des
milliards de milliards de mètres cubes
d'eau dans des centrales nucléaires ou
des barrages hydroélectriques
ces barrages retiennent l'hôpital pour
les arbres situés à laval et empêche le
déplacement des poissons
qui d'entre vous se souvient de l'orc
willy vous savez celui qui réussit à
sauter au dessus d'une digue pour
retrouver sa liberté
mauvaise nouvelle les poissons n'y
arrive pas
ingo longin présent des grandes étendues
utilisés pour l'agriculture
elle sait qu'elle est indispensable pour
alimenter les hommes puisque 70% des
gouttes d'eau utilisée dans le monde
certes à faire pousser des fruits des
légumes ou à abreuver les troupeaux elle
a lu qu'il fallait 13000 lido pour
obtenir un kilo de steak we sing off
traîne sur facebook
13 mètres cubes 13 tonnes d'eau pour une
côte de boeuf
comme ça vient des réseaux sociaux c'est
forcément vrai mais ingo n'en revient
pas
elle découvre aussi le gaspillage
lorsqu'elle se retrouve dans le réseau
d'alimentation en eau potable
ces tuyaux qui apporte l'eau jusqu'à
notre robinet découvre les fuites les
robinets qui reste ouvert la
surconsommation
en nouvelle calédonie certaines communes
enregistrent des consommations qui vont
jusqu'à 1600 litres par jour et par
personne
c'est très soit plus que la consommation
quotidienne d'un parisien et soixante
six fois plus que celle d'à nos gardes
et
d'ailleurs c'est ton d'où vient l'eau
qui coule à nos robinets
et que notre eau est de meilleure
qualité si la forêt dont elle est issue
et en bon état
après avoir été utilisée comme eau
potable
jusque dans nos toilettes ingo se
retrouve dans le réseau des eaux usées
elle a peur elle n'est plus belle et
bleu elle est devenue grise très fausse
et
l angoisse de savoir si elle va rester
de cette couleur toute sa vie car sa
ruine complètement son profil instagram
s'il ya des fosses septiques en sortie
des maisons ou des stations d'épuration
pour l'assainissement collectif peu
d'obligations existants le monde à ce
jour c'est la porte ouverte à la
pollution des rivières et des océans par
les bactéries issues des matières
fécales
seuls 20% des eaux utilisées dans les
maisons seront traitées et nettoyer
avant d'être rejetées dans la nature
20%
ingo retrouve à présent le lagon ses
cocotiers ses plages de sable blanc
enfin presque
elle repense à tous les cas qu'elle a
croisés avant à tous les cas qu'elle a
croisés avant
tout l'effet ch'ti side et les métaux
polluants
bref elle réalise qu'elle est
indispensable pour les arbres les
poissons mais aussi les mines
l'industrie l'agriculture l'eau potable
l'eau de baignade
partagé entre fierté et découragement
à côté de ça
d'autres goutte d'eau qui ont visité
d'autres pays lui raconte levi rivalité
d'usagers qui existe autour de l'eau le
nil par exemple qui traversent en ce
pays et abreuvent 500 millions de
personnes est au coeur de fortes
tensions politiques et militaires
ingo comprend que grâce à elle des
guerres sont déclarés
ouais ok j'avoue ça va pas fort pour
ingo heureusement elle vient m'en
parlent ils jurent manque le moral ça
évite qu'on retrouve trop
d'antidépresseurs dans ses analyses
qualité
pour vous dire quand même si ingo était
tombé sur la côte ouest des états unis
en juillet 2021 elle aurait été témoin
de la plus grave sécheresse de ces 70
dernières années elle se serait sûrement
évaporé avant même d'avoir touché le sol
exactement au même moment singo était
tombé en europe elle aurait participé
aux inondations qui ont noyé 230
personnes en allemagne et en belgique
toujours à la même minute
singo était tombé à madagascar elle
aurait pu aider ces millions de
personnes qui font face à la famine
famine due à un manque d'eau chronique
liée aux déforestations massives dans ce
pays
pour ingo c'en est trop et elle m'a
transmis un message
chers amis vous est composé à 70% deux
gouttes d'eau
je suis donc inquiète et effrayés pour
votre santé votre survie
mon cycle naturel qui est lié à celui
des forêts se dérègle depuis de
nombreuses années canicules inondations
sécheresses incendie incontrôlable sont
autant d' alerte que vous n'écoutez pas
qu'est ce que vous ne comprenez pas
qu'est ce qui vous empêche d'agir qu'est
ce qui vous gêne c'est la musique
larmoyante c'est ça
guaino ce te plaît arrête la musique
larmoyante tu arrêtes la musique je te
plaît ouais t'as pas autre chose
dans mes guaino mais t'es sérieux là on
élève fondé laisse tomber
préserver la nature ce n'est pas
uniquement protéger les baleines les
tigres ou les pandas vous pouvez agir
par exemple en consommant des aliments
issus d'une agriculture durable ou en
réduisant votre consommation de viande
est ça ça c'est une double bonne idée -
de consommer et moins de méthane dans
notre atmosphère
privilégiez les produits fabriqués par
des entreprises respectueuses de
l'environnement
pourquoi ne pas boycotter les banques et
les industries qui ne jouent pas le jeu
vous pouvez agir autour de vous sans
attendre le vote d'une loi
vous pouvez aussi agir en utilisant
mieux l'eau de pluie ou en veillant
chaque jour à ne pas gaspiller l'eau et
quelle folie que d'acheter de l'eau en
bouteille quand on en a de la bonne
robin et surtout des bouteilles
qui font le tour du monde c'est du
n'importe quoi
mais là elle est très énervé
mais surtout n'hésitez plus à les
planter des arbres avec les associations
le week end bougez-vous pour les forêts
et les zones humides à côté de chez vous
ce sont des éponges naturelles qui sont
menacés et qu'il faut à tout prix
protéger
sans forêt l'eau disparaît et s'il vous
plaît arrêtez le chacun pour soi
asseyez-vous autour d'une table et
parler
partager vos idées pour mieux partager
l'eau
je m'appelle ingo je suis une petite
goutte d'eau
[Applaudissements]
j'avoue l'histoire bingo est triste mais
il nous appartient de changer son destin
de réécrire son histoire pour qu'elle
devienne belle dans le futur et c'est
possible finalement chaque jour par des
bonnes actions de la part de chacun
d'entre nous ingo a raison
l'eau c'est notre vie l'eau c'est notre
lien l'eau c'est notre partage
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]